and now a message from your local nerd  rider oh sorry didn't see you there hi  I'm the nerd rider and this week I'm on  my fifty second blog that's a year's  worth of vlogs so it's sort of a special  occasion so what I'm gonna do is a  question and answer vlog now people have  asked me a lot of stuff in the comments  before and I've never really answered  anything outright so here's your chance  ask me anything you want in the comments  of this video and next week I'll do a  vlog where I answer as many as I can  also if you haven't watched my blog from  last week vlog 51 New York City please  do and vote for me and my destination  calms the biggest baddest bucket list if  you think it would be cool to see me  show you and teach you the world I think  it would be pretty cool well actually  I'd love to stay and talk more but I  have a prior engagement so ask your  questions I'll see you next time